TERRY RYAN: Let's launch a
PHP application on App Engine
flexible environment.
I have a simple Hello
World PHP application.
I can run it locally
or in Docker,
but now we want to
run it on App Engine.
The first thing I
need to do is sign
into Google Cloud Platform.
Once I sign in, I need
to create a new project.
Now that I have my project,
I need to go Compute Engine
and make sure
billing is enabled.
Now I need to initialize the
project on my computer using
GCloud init.
It If you do not
have the Google Cloud
SDK installed on your computer,
download it from our website.
Now we need to create an app
[? EML ?] file to configure
this application on App Engine.
Make sure to point App
Engine to the folder
where it can find
your application.
In our case, it's in web.
Once that is done, deploy the
App Engine using the command
GCloud app deploy.
First time deployment
may take a few minutes.
Now the application is up and
running with PHP on App Engine
flexible environment.